[Music]
all right guys
bang bang i've got harry here thanks so
much for doing this man i'm excited to
be here my first time in miami too so
i'm glad we could do it in person
yeah absolutely uh let's talk about
ride sharing and from specifically from
the driver's side
uh i don't think i understood until a
couple years ago
that drivers are basically just small
business owners yeah
walk me through kind of your journey
from you were working at a tech company
i think right and then you became a
uber driver and then eventually kind of
went and built this whole digital media
business focused on
educating and empowering people who are
driving in this gig economy
yeah like how do you see the driver as
like a small business yeah i mean that's
actually really a good
starting point because a lot of people
get into the gig economy they get into
driving for uber and lyft or delivering
doordash or groceries for instacart to
make a couple hundred bucks a week you
know side income
flexible you know there are a lot of
positive attributes and what they don't
end up realizing is they are running
their own business they get paid
via 10.99 and i mean as you know and
many of your
folks in your audience know running a
business is tough tough job right it's a
tough gig it's not for everyone most
businesses fail
for a reason because you not only have
to think about your income you have to
think about your expenses you have to
think about your liabilities like
insurance you have to think about
taxes estimated taxes as a 1099 worker
right you don't get
taxes taken out of your paycheck so it
could come hit you especially if you
don't do a good job tracking
all of your mileage and so i actually
started my my former career i was an
aerospace engineer for boeing so kind of
doing the exact opposite of what i do
now
um but that was sort of my my formal
training so i worked as an engineer for
seven years and
in those last few years of my uh
engineering career
i started dabbling in online businesses
doing i had a
few personal finance blogs that i
started just for fun started doing some
freelance travel writing
just kind of you know scoping out the
opportunities and the options working
online and in digital media and what i
enjoyed
and one day you know kind of like a lot
of people back in 2014
heard about this service called uber
heard about the service called lyft
and it just seemed like an interesting
gig to try
driving for and especially in those
early days i mean i was an engineer so i
was tracking all of my income and i was
making
a lot of money and the pay has
definitely come down since those early
days i mean i remember
you know doing a podcast um back in 2014
my first
weekend driving july 4th weekend in
newport beach california which is like a
big
party area and also making over 50 an
hour you know and this is here i'm
working as an engineer making a decent
salary but i was making more driving for
uber and lyft you know just on the
weekends and nights
than i was at my day job yeah and so
when you think about um
kind of today it seems like there's uh
what i'll call the unsophisticated
driver who
hey i just get my car that's pretty much
all i need to get started i turn on the
app i get signed up and i'm off to the
races it tells me to go pick up person
you know
spot a i take them to where it tells me
drop them off and just move on with my
day
then there's some people i've talked to
some of these drivers who are super
sophisticated
they know exactly where surge is they
know exactly kind of how to be efficient
they know how to get the highest rates
they start to figure out all kinds of
things of how to get this ride shorter
do they want long rides and fewer uh in
kind of a shift do they want tons of
short rides right like
yeah how do you think through that and
is there kind of like
one strategy that works across the
country for sure or is it different in
kind of each geography
well the crazy thing about working in
the gig economy is that there's so much
variability right you've probably talked
to other drivers who absolutely hate the
job you know they can't figure it out
they're not making more than minimum
wage you've probably seen stories about
that and those are actually true
um you know on average drivers report
you know in the annual surveys we've
done like over a thousand drivers they
report
report earning about 15 to 20 an hour
before expenses
right now in the mid you know coming out
of this pandemic there's a bit of a
driver supply
issue which we i'm sure we'll talk about
so earnings are up but
you know just to kind of give you an
average and then from there you know the
worst drivers are making five to ten but
the best are 20 to 30. if you're in a
bigger city where there's more demand
los angeles chicago miami
you can make more money just kind of at
a baseline average level
but definitely there are drivers who are
you know what we've seen
actually in in uber's own data that
they've released the more experience you
have as a driver
actually it has an impositive impact on
your earnings so you might earn maybe
five to ten dollars an hour
more after one thousand five thousand
trips and so what my really my whole
business
has been trying to do is accelerate that
learning curve now obviously we've got
courses and things like that for drivers
but also just content and really
understanding i mean number one
is that you know the company's
incentives and your own incentives are
not always aligned right
and so i think that that actually
applies in every
job you know i mean people think that
you know i worked at this company for 30
years i mean if things go south you're
you know there's no reason that they
wouldn't lay you off so i think it's
just a good principle to understand and
in the gig economy
there's really not a lot of loyalty or
love lost on either side drivers you
know obviously many of them do uber and
lyft or
switch over to food delivery and the
same thing on the company side so there
definitely are
strategies that you can employ and i
would say that it kind of
you know the main principle that applies
across every city and state is really
just understanding that
nobody cares more about your income than
you do not every trip
that the companies send you is going to
be one that you want i mean you talked
about short trips for example like i
learned very quickly
driving in newport beach seven years ago
that the worst trips are the short trips
those are the ones
so on a short trip anything two to three
miles or less
uber typically charges you know the
rates vary by city but it's let's say
seven to ten dollars let's say ten
dollars for
even around numbers from there they take
a three dollar service fee
you know round numbers right that goes
straight to the company so that leaves
seven dollars
and then from that seven dollars uber
takes 25
so the driver is only getting 75 of
seven dollars right so let's and you
know
let's say it's like four to five dollars
in other cities that minimum fare is
actually a lot lower like in la
that end payout on a minimum trip was
two dollars and 80 cents for a long time
and so you could imagine all the work
that goes into even a short trip right
so you're only getting 28 percent
basically of a ten dollar trip when it's
all said and done you're
on minimum fares you're usually getting
like 40 to 50
right um even though their take rate
right they'll say that their take rate
is 25
so you know it's like we would employ
strategies to avoid
those minimum fares you know like at
nights from like 10
p.m to 12 a.m when people are kind of
bar hopping you want to stay away
from those areas right you kind of
actually want to drop people off and
then drive away
a few miles so you don't get pulled in
you know for like a one mile someone
really hammered you know they're waiting
they're making you wait 5-10 minutes
you know when you're outside um type of
trip and is there things that
uh drivers do in terms of understanding
like geography so like airport is a
pretty obvious one there should be
always you know persistent demand in a
big city
at the airport for somebody who needs an
uber and so you can basically go there
take them go back
you know and that's like kind of one
strategy obviously night life right hey
if there's a downtown area you're
you kind of go out where people live and
then you take them in and then
uh reverse at the end of the night right
it is at 2 am go downtown
and take them wherever they get but are
there other types of geographic
based strategies that you see drivers
really kind of optimize their income
i mean the dummy proof strategy is sort
of just to drive the times when it's
high demand so that would be monday
through friday rush hour
you know especially now that things are
opening up and coming back so mornings
and then late afternoons
and then also friday saturday night
drivers call those the party hours and
you know really the later you stay
the less drivers are out so the more you
can make via surge pricing
so those would be sort of that's kind of
like the dummy proof strategy and then
as far as geographically
you know i will say that you know just
at a high level right like the cities
that are the biggest cities in the u.s
typically like that's where earnings are
the highest because demand
is the strongest i mean cost of living
is sometimes higher there but
um you know we do see drivers you know
even who live
you know near the san francisco bay area
like go to san francisco and drive for a
weekend you know get an
airbnb share with real people yeah
because i mean san francisco is probably
you know a very unique market because
i you know high demand but also like i
would say like insane demand just
because you know so many of these apps
started there so many people are
you know using these you know uh options
and you know there's
so literally people will leave where
they live they'll go to let's say san
francisco and a bunch of other drivers
may get an airbnb together and then
literally they'll like work the weekend
and then they go back to wherever they
uh live yep crazy
what's the difference between driving
for an uber and lyft which i think when
people think of gig economy drivers
that's what they think of
with maybe food delivery or some of the
other types of driving in the gig
economy so i would say pre-pandemic you
know it really was uber and lyft were
sort of like the top dogs but i mean now
you look at you know coming out of the
pandemic i mean doordash is a 50 billion
dollar market cap company right like
they're a real competitor you know they
may even be surpassing uber sometime
soon i just had
doordash's president on my podcast and
he was dropping stats left and right and
they've got two million dashers right
now on the platform right so
you know in the same ballpark as uber
who said they've got two to three
million drivers and
you know the main difference i would
actually say happens on
the kind of vehicle side so it's really
sort of you know for the company's
acquisition funnel they have a much
bigger pool
of workers to choose from because you
can really drive with any old piece of
[ __ ] on food delivery i mean you can
have
your own car obviously but you can also
do a scooter you can do a bike you can
do an e-bike
you can deliver with a friend or family
member which some people
definitely do salvage vehicle really
two-door anything you know i actually
had someone drop off a doordash order
the other day and he pulled up in a
range rover
really a few years old but it was a
range rover that was one of the nicest
cars i've ever seen
yeah and so basically uber and lyft have
a higher standard because
there's actual customers of their
exactly versus food delivery basically
the the gist is you sort of need a newer
four-door vehicle
no damage no salvage title no funky
colors stuff like that
um so that's sort of you know one big
difference and then on the supply side
you know it's made a big difference if
you've noticed you know for those who
are
kind of power users of these food
delivery services there was a bit of
issues on doordash and instacart at the
start of the pandemic when they had a
big spike in demand but since then
they've been very reliable um you know
when placing orders especially relative
to their counterparts uber on left so
the vehicles
is one and then there are some
differences on the driver's side
just you know sort of the obvious that
you know you're obviously interacting
less to none with passengers so if
you're more of an introvert that might
be a better option
yeah what's so fascinating was uh in new
york and then here in miami
uh when i came down here uh all of these
um apartment buildings
they wouldn't let the food delivery go
up to the actual doors and i remember
saying to myself like they must save so
much time
right yeah not having to get in the
elevator go up and find the door knock
wait for the person to answer the door
go back all the time you just walk in
put her at the front desk and leave
and uh it just reminds you that like
literally five minutes ten minutes could
be two or three extra trips which could
be more revenue
and you kind of understand the economics
of the business well and that's a
perfect example of actually you know how
geographies do matter because you know
where i'm from in los angeles we don't
have as many of the big towers but we do
have these mega apartment complexes
where drivers kind of have to navigate
it on their own
and they do have to take it to people's
doorsteps i saw an integration that uber
eats um has in the works and it's
actually with a company
though it actually like gives more
detail in these mega apartment complexes
to solve
this exact situation and so as a driver
on especially in the delivery services
you get a lot more information
about each trip and so you might want to
make those types of decisions and
understand hey there's certain buildings
you know
this building in midtown miami like they
make you take it up to the customer
these other ones don't
right and that extra five to ten minutes
like honestly frankly like usually the
customer doesn't know they don't care
they don't think about it
and if it costs you 10 minutes to make
that extra delivery it's literally
cutting into your
utilization basically right and that's
kind of what i mean
in that you know the people that have
the best success in the gig economy are
thinking about it like a business right
this is only one trip and it's only five
ten bucks but i mean that principle adds
up over time if you get ten of those a
week right and you can save an
extra you know 60 to 100 minutes every
single week and do more deliveries
you're making more
have people made like automated systems
where it basically can read
when the or you know when the order
comes in or when the ride request comes
in it basically gives you you know
a plus type ride you know it's it's f
minus
type ride or delivery like are there
ways for them to almost automate that
decision making
yeah really just based on best guess and
maybe some information to help me
there have been a couple cool startups
that have tried to do things like that
one that i worked with called maestro
basically kind of automated your uber
and lyft driving so a lot of drivers do
both services and this was kind of a
hack that worked through the android
those android only and it worked through
the accessibility's option and basically
what it did
it would put you you would hit one
button it would put you online in both
uber and lyft when you got a trip
request it would accept it based on what
whatever parameters you had set you know
it's like oh anthony pompliano he's a
4.7 uber i only want 4.8 or above right
you know surge rating things like that
and they actually ended up running into
a lot of issues with lyft lyft started
like kind of actively blocking
the company and releasing software
updates there's another interesting app
right now
in the dasher community called para that
is actually giving
dashers more information about each trip
so
with doordash right now you see the
total amount including tips but
sometimes if it's a really big tip
doordash doesn't provide that
information to drivers because they sort
of don't want people just cherry-picking
the best trips you know the best orders
and this app is actually telling dashers
you know they sort of have found this
loophole this workaround where they tell
you okay no this one has an extra 15
tip and so it's a bit controversial
right now and some people are sort of
for using it and others aren't but uh
you know that's what's going down on the
ground level yeah it's fascinating to me
and then i guess um in terms of like
actual
uh investing and kind of the financial
empowerment right so
you talked earlier about uh somebody
with a car on the weekend or at night if
even if they've got another job or if
they do this full-time
is a great way for them to make some
extra money yeah uh how sophisticated
are most of the drivers in terms of uh
investing
yeah are you know one of the jokes
always in finance has been like uh be
scared when your barber asks you about
stocks
i'll tell you this story and this was
absolutely crazy i went to dinner in new
york city maybe a month ago
uh i got in the car it was you know 11
30 at night or something after dinner
and all of a sudden my wife slapped my
leg and
you know i look up and uh the
uber driver had stopped at uh a red
light
and he had the phone kind of on like the
the device holding it up
and all of a sudden he clicked out of
the uber app and he clicked into robin
hood
nice and literally was looking at
dogecoin making some trades
not trading like you know nothing like
that but just like
that was the chat that he chose to click
into and so i couldn't
say hey what are you doing or whatever
like just trying to understand the
psyche basically and he was like look
like i'm bored in the car a lot of
waiting for rides whatever he's like
it's just fascinating i don't know that
much
right i'm trying to learn like all the
stuff and so maybe dogecoin isn't the
place to go
right but it started just it got me
thinking like how sophisticated
are you know many of these drivers are
there programs in place for them to
learn
yeah they are making money right is
there ways for them to invest like yeah
what do you see on that front well i
mean i will say
you know just to be frank like
unfortunately i think a lot of drivers
are you know more paycheck to paycheck
and even though this income is nice it's
extra its side like usually the money is
going to
important causes i guess i would say you
know to make up for their other job and
you know to pay the rent or to pay food
or to pay the bills or to pay off
things and so you know to the company's
credit they have launched some pretty
cool stuff you know partnerships with
like betterment in the past uber has a
pretty cool partnership right now
i want to say it's like with the
university of tempe or something like
that where if you drive a certain number
of hours you can work on your degree
online on the side so they do have a lot
of cool stuff
like that at your disposal but frankly i
think more drivers are
i wouldn't say they're not sophisticated
but i just would say that they have kind
of other priorities you know more like
immediate needs and priorities and so
you know we definitely
try to do some work on the investment
you know like we we did a whole series
recently called like kind of developing
your plan b
because we sort of noticed like last
month i had more unsubscribers and i had
subscribers on my
you know 80 000 person email list and we
started surveying a bunch of them and
they're like oh no we love your content
we're just moving on
to other stuff right because the nature
of the gig economy is very
transient um you know a lot of people
get into it for certain reasons but it
isn't
the thing they want to do forever i mean
i always i'm a big fan
of just leveraging it for a lot of the
reasons you talked about but also i
think it's just amazing practice at
running an actual
business right because you're doing all
the things of
someone who operates a multi-million
dollar business you literally have all
of the same
kind of requirements things to think
about goals objectives and it might be
on a smaller scale obviously but
it is a great practice so i would love
to see more people
kind of get into the gig economy kind of
like how i did like i was working
at boeing and frankly like a lot of
people kind of made fun of me when i
started driving for uber and lyft seven
years ago and i'm like telling them no
i'm literally on a dollar per hour
amount making more
and then when i deduct all of my mileage
right now the mileage deduction is 57.5
cents per mile
i'm making you know this is like tax
free how does that work so
as a driver you know a full-time driver
believe it or not puts a lot of miles on
their car so
they'll do a thousand miles a week and
you get a 57.5
mile deduction so that's 575 dollars
let's say you make a thousand dollars
on that one thousand miles driven right
off the bat you're 1 000 minus 575
dollars so that's only 4.25
then that's taxable income it's tax so
you're only paying taxes on 425
right and then you have your cell phone
right you might be you know when you're
uber driving it's online all the time
and if you look at your
you know you maybe use your phone 10
hours a week and use it 40 hours a week
for uber so now it's 40 divided by 50 80
of your cell phone bill is now
deductible now you know you're driving
you know you're driving all over the
place right you can really start to add
up a lot of those miles i did this cool
experiment in los angeles
uber has a feature called destination
filter where you can only get rides
headed in the direction you want to go
you can even set a time that you need to
be an arrival time basically right and
so
anytime for a whole month i had a
meeting i had somewhere to go just like
on personal side right
friends i wasn't like working driving
for uber it was just whenever i had to
leave the house i set that destination
filter
and i was actually very surprised at you
know i would go out of the way i would
make
eight bucks 10 bucks 15 bucks when you
looked at the time
spent you know basically your marginal
time like it would have taken me 15
minutes to get there
now it only took me 20 minutes it was
only five minutes but i made an extra
eight bucks right
eight times 12 is now 96 dollars an hour
i didn't actually make 96 an hour
but you know eight dollars in five
minutes right is not bad so
there are some pretty cool ways uh that
you can leverage it and i mean even
you know i just think if more people
knew about how powerful it was i mean
they've got an instant pay option too so
you can literally
go out work one trip you know let's say
you get a big trip 50 bucks you can cash
it out and it's like a fast cash
so it gets two years you know it's like
a reverse atm transaction it gets to
your bank account in like five to 15
minutes so
there's some pretty cool stuff happening
you're much more sophisticated
than most uber drivers i think yeah
right you literally were an aerospace
engineer you've obviously done all the
math etc
how do people get from hey i'm just
starting i don't even understand how to
run a business to like your level of
sophistication i'm assuming that's a lot
of what the digital business that you
have
yeah i mean so the way that i think most
people do it is just through experience
right they just do
thousands of trips i mean my my driver
here i think it said on the app you know
that he had 15 000 trips and so i think
if you know if you're making it 15 000
trips you're figuring things out on your
own what i try to do and help people
with is accelerate
that learning curve right i mean once
you get five ten thousand trips you kind
of know all the tricks you know
how long does that take five thousand
trips um i mean if you're driving
full-time you could probably knock
out a hundred trips a week so one year
you could do five thousand i mean that's
full-time full-time you know 40 to 50
hours so it's serious stuff you know if
you do 5000 trips a year you're pretty
serious
about it and frankly you know a lot of
people don't make it that long in the
gig economy uber released a stat
saying that two-thirds of all drivers
quit after just six months
so you sort of had to have a lot of
newbies and you have a lot of veterans
like people who have figured out the
system and there aren't that many people
in between who are kind of just you know
dangling what's up guys bang bang i hope
you're enjoying this conversation but
before we go any further i want to
quickly tell you about today's sponsor
block five block five's got four
different financial products for crypto
investors
you can deposit crypto and earn up to
eight point six percent apy
in an interest bearing account you can
deposit crypto and take out a us dollar
loan against your crypto collateral
you can use our cryptocurrency exchange
and have no trading fees
or you can get a new bitcoin rewards
credit card it's a normal credit card
that when you swipe you get bitcoin back
rather than cash back or airline miles
i'm an investor in the business and a
very happy user
i think you will be too when you go to
blockfy.com
pomp again blockfy.com go check it out
and let me know what you think
all right let's get back into this
conversation i hope you enjoy it what's
going on with the driver shortage right
i think that's one of the
the most fascinating things so most
people uh they realize hey the prices
seem to be a little bit higher
uh you see all types of weird stuff over
the last few months like
uh i can get the uber xl cheaper than i
can
for like a normal ride and um yeah it
all i think revolves around this driver
shortage
so like how do you view that than that
you're kind of an insider to this
industry
uh and then what are the pros and cons
when there's a driver shortage sure yeah
and i mean i think that a lot of people
i'm still talking to people every day
especially on the west coast they're
taking their first uber trip
in you know a year year and a half and
they're like what the hell is going on i
can't get a ride prices are at an
all-time high and
you know frankly i think reliability is
at an all-time low for these services
and what's really happening i guess the
root cause of the driver's shoulder i
mean there are a few reasons but i think
the main thing is that a lot of these
drivers
are still getting unemployment they're
still getting ppp there's a big change
to the ppp
program from gross income or from net
income to gross income and because of
all those tax deductions we talked about
like the net income
of a full-time driver is really low
which means is great because you pay no
taxes
and you know it doesn't actually cost
57.5 cents per mile to operate your
vehicle it's more like 20 to 30
20 to 30 cents if you've got a good car
a good prius and got a good deal
and so a lot of drivers are still on
that unemployment they still got ppp
loans there's other programs like
employee retention credit
which drivers if they convert to an llc
as s corp are eligible for
and we worked with a partner who
basically did that and signed up
hundreds of drivers for that so
you know i think that's really the main
cause for a lot of this and then the
second thing like i talked about earlier
i mean delivery is here to stay right
food delivery there's still a lot of
questions about the unit economics of
the business but doordash
50 billion market cap right over the
pandemic their demand
exploded on all of the last mile
delivery services and so they hired
hundreds of thousands of drivers they
also brought a lot of people over
from uber and lyft and so i think what's
happening now is you know there's this
sort of
you know unemployment stimulus is a big
cause but then also you know a lot of
people
are now doing delivery or have switched
uh over to delivery and you know they're
real competitors so
i think that uh you know that's kind of
what's driving that uh shortage that so
dara from uber had this uh kind of tweet
storm where
he basically said hey prices are higher
right
and okay that that was a pretty big step
of just acknowledging yes prices are
higher
uh but then he tried to walk through
kind of the unit economics of why this
actually may be better for drivers and
like drivers are making more
so uh i know it might get a little grain
but walk us through kind of the
if you want to get granular we can
you've got a smart audience yeah we'll
make people understand when the prices
go up
uh can you give us an example of how the
drivers are actually making more money
versus
the company itself making more money so
uber has basically
switched to a really interesting system
where they've
decoupled what the passenger pays with
what the driver gets so in that example
i talked to you before with the 10
fare you could always back calculate
exactly what you got as a driver and it
was based off the actual mileage and
time and you could see the service fee
subtract that out and then you would get
your 75 of the remaining fare
and what a lot of these companies are
frankly trying to do is that they see
there's a lot of earnings volatility
right sometimes drivers are making way
more
sometimes they're making way less and it
can you know cause a lot of retention
issues over time so what they're trying
to do or at least this is what they say
is they're basically just trying to
remove some of that volatility
and pay the same right which in
financial terms obviously if you had two
different opportunities
one is more volatile you would pick the
one that's less volatile if the expected
return
was the same right and so what that's
what a lot of these programs are trying
to do and so
now when what dara's tweet storm was
basically saying was that you know
there's an article in the washington
post that said
hey you know when you pay more when you
pay that hundred dollars for that surge
ride right now that normally costs you
25
drivers aren't actually getting more of
that fare and that is true
so on a hundred so let's say you have a
25 base fare
you know from your house to the airport
for example a little bit of a longer
trip
um if there's a 4x surge on that and it
now costs you 100
kind of an extreme situation the driver
is getting what's called a flat rate
surge
so there's a big map on the driver's
side and it's actually kind of cool if
you if you're a customer you can
actually sign up as a driver and then
you can pull up the surge map and see
what prices look like just as a little
hack if you want to avoid surge pricing
and you can move your pin around and you
know get cheaper areas but
basically they get paid a flat rate so
they get 25 plus anywhere from a few
dollars
5 10 15 it might be more like 15 in this
case
so they're only getting paid let's say
40 on this individual trip
where you the customer are paying 100 so
uber's take and i'm simplifying the math
a bit but uber's take is 60
on that trip and drivers actually see
that on their receipt
and so they go to reddit they go to
forums they go to sites like mine and
they're like harry what the hell is
going on uber is taking 60
now they're usually ignoring the trips
where uber is taking a lot less
or there are even trips where uber is
losing money uberpool um
used to actually some trips if it didn't
match the company would actually lose
money
right and so what dara was basically
trying to explain was that their take
rate has actually gone down
so on average what they're taking from
drivers you know
has gone down across the board so that
means there are a bunch of short trips
right where they're sort of paying a
higher bonus than what drivers would
have got
on the old system and i think why it's
so interesting is that
i you know i totally believed r i don't
think he's making these numbers up right
but there's a big disconnect between
what the drivers see
and what they're experiencing you know
on an individual trip level and i think
that psychology is really interesting
for companies to understand because
i don't think uber and lyft are doing a
good job of showing like they should be
getting credit like hey we're paying
drivers more we should get credit for
this
and if you go in and talk to drivers how
much uber takes from each fare i
guarantee they would say
crazy numbers 30 40 50 60 but the
average take rate is usually
more in that 30 to 40 percent range um
and we've kind of analyzed this a bunch
of times over the years i have drivers
sending me all their
trips right now and we're doing some
cool analyses but
you know there's sort of like this
disconnect between what the companies
are seeing at an aggregate level and how
they communicate that
to drivers on an individual level it's
fascinating to me
that the math and the psychology is
separated yeah it shouldn't be
surprising
it's all the finance but it just feels
like uber and lyft
are never gonna get credit i mean i
think that
a little bit of this is self-inflicted
though like i think that you know they
definitely
you know they've got their you know
detractors people who sort of you know
have a negative uh view of them and you
know and obviously i run a whole
business on helping
drivers and gig workers so my view of
the gig economy is optimistic i'm more
you know we cover the positives and
negatives for sure
you know but i'm more positive than
negative and i think that it's just
important because the perception of
earnings
is often more important than your actual
earnings
right and so that's like i feel like
what the companies don't quite get
they're looking at their data and
they've got these spreadsheets and this
is one thing
i've criticized the companies i think
they do look at drivers actually i know
they do i've been in their office with
them and they're literally talking about
drivers like numbers on a spreadsheet
like hey
you know we know that we lose this many
drivers and we can replace them
for this cost you know times new drivers
and that's cheaper than
you know retaining good drivers right
and so but i think it kind of like
hurts them when it comes to these
situations where like [ __ ] has sort of
hit the fan
and now they need drivers and they can't
convince people to come back they're
like i got an
in-app notification the other day
drivers are earning median 31 dollars
per hour and that's across
all engaged time you know even when
you're sitting there waiting for a trip
which they usually don't account for in
their calculations
um and you know drivers are kind of like
eh i'm gonna stick with delivery for now
you know maybe i'll come back to uber in
the future
or like oh i don't really trust them or
oh it'll probably only last for a little
bit it feels like if they could just say
hey our average take rate from you yeah
right is x percent they just told you
that number and it was a
attractive number drivers should be like
thank you right like
i don't know and i mean i think that
they've tested some things in the past
you know like on rides where they take a
60 70
commission they give an extra little
bonus like kind of like a ketchup but i
think that
um they need to do a much better job of
you know sort of i mean you really kind
of have to balance being super
because if you're like too transparent
and you show drivers exactly
what's happening and how much they're
taking you know like i just worked my
ass off
to pick up this guy you know i had to
wait for him for five minutes and then
there was all this traffic and then i
only got 40
of the fare like that's sort of like a
slap in the face and of course as a
driver
i'm gonna remember that trip and forget
the one where uber lost a couple bucks
right
and so you sort of have to think about
the best ways to be transparent but also
like
get credit when you do do something well
and i think that's what
the companies you know i mean it's not
an impossible challenge to solve so
i'm confident that they will eventually
solve it but uh probably to you know i
think right now
it's hurting them a lot more and you
know one of the reasons why they're
experiencing you know i mentioned uber
and lyft are at a reliability
as an all-time low i mean they use surge
pricing in the past i mean their number
one kpi
has always been when you open the app
they want you to see a driver available
and then they want you to see it
three to five minutes away and that's
really not happening right now so i
think it's like
five alarm fire at the company right now
uh last thing i want to talk about is
bitcoin a trend that we've seen across
industries uh from professional athletes
all the way down yeah getting paid in
bitcoin
yeah is that a thing in uh uber lyft and
kind of delivery and uh type drivers do
they want to get paid in bitcoin or have
access to other types of financial
assets
or are they just living paycheck to pay
like give me the dollars and move on
i mean i think that for now they're kind
of like paycheck to paycheck want the
dollars but i do think that you know
we've seen you know
kind of like with the rise of you know
bitcoin on its own and then you know
especially like the beginning of the
pandemic when people did have those
stimulus checks and maybe we're
investing more and you know like public
markets gambling whatever you want to
call it
or um you know stock market is a casino
for sure
right and so we definitely have seen
that kind of like ebb and flow with more
like based on the macro trends i haven't
seen
a ton of demand you know i guess you
would say but i do think that that would
be
pretty cool like i think that there is a
lot more opportunity to sort of get like
some of these drivers involved in some
of the
crypto assets and then also like even
you know some of these like local
merchants especially on the food
delivery side you know like sort of
getting paid you know accepting payment
in bitcoin or you know whatever it might
be and then how
the driver fits into that equation you
know getting bonuses or cash back and
all these companies have
driver rewards programs so i could
easily see you know hey instead of
getting like this certain bonus it's
like you get you know whatever
percentage of bitcoin a bitcoin coin
right back so
definitely some cool stuff yeah there's
um there's a lot of uh studies that show
people
don't care so much about the dollar
amount yeah like a gift or
of uh some sort of reward etc exactly
it's the actual
thought so like for example um you could
give somebody a five dollar
trinket or you could say i'll give you a
hundred dollars yeah and
although it is a non-economic decision
yeah there are studies that show people
will choose the five dollar trinket
because it has
sentimental meaning or whatever now i'm
not saying that uber and lyft should go
give
five dollar trinkets right no i mean
that's a that's a really good idea lyft
used to give out this
jacket at a thousand trips and it was a
pretty nice i mean you know not like
patagonia or anything but you know like
a solid windbreaker
man every driver it was like a watch of
honor they wanted it they wore it you
know i would go to these driver events
these meetups and you could sort of tell
like all the ogs
had their jackets on and so i do think
that there's something there
right like that's why i think it is cool
you know and of course like digital
um goods and services are a lot more
scalable right versus like mailing out
jackets and things like that
but basically swag you know like i when
i came here i gave you a little swag
you know even when i'm opting people
into my email list you know i give them
a pdf guide to driving right because
it's sort of like that psychological
hey if you're going to give me your
email i want to give you something in
return like how valuable is this pdf
that i'm sending i mean there's some
good info in there but it's not like you
know the most valuable thing in the
world so i do think that
kind of rewards like it doesn't and
again like i think that's where
you know these companies still have a
lot of i would look at it as like
opportunity to improve things to improve
their relationships with like small
stuff like that that you know isn't
you know because all these companies
want to kind of avoid just giving cash
to their drivers right they really want
to actually take more cash
right on a kind of unit economics basis
so i do think you know thinking about
like
you know going off of like what the
current trends are like i actually bet
you you know like if you could find a
way to like hook up some drivers with
some dogecoin
right now like i bet you a lot of them
would be kind of like psyched about her
like you know now bonuses they say like
hey come out
do three trips for a hundred bucks so
uber got me back on the road after a
year and a half of no driving during the
pandemic
they sent all these drivers say hey do
three trips get a hundred dollars i was
like
[ __ ] even i'll do that right that's easy
free money kind of my job to try out
these services
did it got my hundred bucks but if it
was like do five trips get a dogecoin or
you know whatever percentage of a
dogecoin
i bet that would be like whoa you know
like that would really stand out and
it's been crazy like that three four
hundred dollars a lot of drivers were
like
yeah i'm over it i don't need to sounds
good to be true
like it you know normally the market is
very elastic and they really have a lot
of manual
levers that they can pull and push with
bonuses if they see inclement weather is
coming up they know that demand
is going to spike a little bit because
more people want to take an uber than
they want to walk
right and so they'll increase the
bonuses a little bit to get more drivers
onto the platform
or to take drivers from other services
and so they've had all these levers at
their disposals over the years with
financial incentives and now
they're putting those levers down and
they're not working they're like hey
normally a 300
bonus that gets everyone back on the
road and now drivers are like eh i got
my unemployment or eh
i'm already driving for doordash and i'm
driving for instacart or
it's like hey you know what i haven't
had a great experience i made a bunch of
money on dogecoin
bitcoin uh before we get into the last
three questions to finish up where can
people go find more information from you
i feel like you're just this wealth of
knowledge around all this stuff so yeah
definitely
some people so uh my website
thereshareguy.com that's sort of the
starting point we've also got a pretty
popular
youtube channel where we release you
know basically daily youtube videos and
especially for more like the industry
perspectives
my podcast is a good spot i just had on
you know the doordash president for
example i've interviewed
dara a couple times on my podcast so
that's really where we sort of try to
combine the workers perspective
with like you know the industry you know
what's happening at a higher level and
you know really just kind of analyze
everything from uh you know the workers
perspective but
yeah so basically type uber lyft
rideshare guy into any box on the
internet and hopefully i should pop up
it's fascinating to me so thank you so
much for for doing all the work
uh three questions then you could ask me
when to finish up all right first what's
the most important book you've ever read
uh the most important book i've ever
read is probably deep work by cal
newport because he's this mit researcher
and i mean i think he's like kind of
semi-famous and sort of like
productivity circles
and like i'm you know as a business
owner we talked about how tough it is
running a business like i don't get paid
to go to conferences right like i'm here
now for a conference um i don't get paid
to
you know do certain things i really have
to like be protective of my time he's
like a big fan
uh basically when i read i'll just say
when i read his book i turned off all
notifications on my phone i only checked
my email once a day now i pause my inbox
i batch process a lot more
and when i do work i really try to get
into deep work he's got this really
cool example of you know when you get a
notification on your phone
basically it only takes a second to look
away but there's actually like a bit of
cognitive drag
going forward so the task at hand is now
going to take longer whether you realize
it or not
just from that like one second
notification so great book that's
definitely true
second question is sleep schedule uh
friends that ate sleep
have this mattress thermoregulated bed
yeah i sleep on it freezing cold
sleep way better what is your sleep
schedule maybe what is the average sleep
schedule do you think of
uber lyft yeah doordash type drivers
where it actually could be
more profitable to work at night yes
during the day et cetera you know i have
to say i think i actually listened to a
few of your podcasts and
hear you always talking about the age i
love it i feel like i'm like a religious
person i don't know
i feel like uh and you know what's crazy
there's actually like some big mattress
bloggers out there that like review all
these services very lucrative
anyways um i and i'm thinking about
i just bought a new bed when i started
hearing about the eight sleep but my my
you know i've got
i've got two kids so let's just preface
it with that okay
but i try to do uh 11 to seven and then
usually if my kids get up early i'm up
closer to six
you know unfortunately i will say though
like if you're working in the gay
economy it kind of
messes with your sleep schedule you know
like the most profitable hours are gonna
be late into the nights on friday and
saturday nights typically
but you don't have to work those friday
saturday nights that's what's so great
about the gay economy you can understand
when those times of high demand are and
balance that
with your schedule with your needs right
like you can still be very profitable
in a bigger city completely skipping
friday saturday nights it honestly might
be tough if you're in a smaller to
medium city
to skip out on those friday saturday
nights and that's the big difference
like
medium small cities versus big cities
like la is always busy
it's just like you can always get a ride
so you know sleep schedule i think
is a little more uh chaotic so i would
say take it when you need it if you're
working in the gay economy
absolutely uh last question is aliens
believer or non-believer
um i mean i think i saw a stat the other
day i did not verify this maybe one of
your listeners can that said there
are more stars in the sky than grains of
sand on this planet so i just
imagine that like how expansive this
place is like there's got to be
something
out there i don't know if it's big or
small but like something
just i think by like pure statistical um
anomalies must have happened and i think
actually neil degrasse tyson just
released
a cool book called cosmic queries that i
started
and was a little too boring for me but
if you're into that i bet it's a good
book
i absolutely think something's out there
it's gotta be right yeah
uh you gotta ask me one question finish
up what do you got for me um all right
so
i'll be honest like miss the bitcoin
train okay i know it's still
available an option but like i do really
think about like these opportunities
like
what do you think is maybe not the next
bitcoin but like what are the tactics or
skills or principles you know that you
would look at like
how do you tell like something that
might be the next bitcoin versus like
this is like a total piece of crap
nothing's gonna be the next bit right
and so uh
opportunities of that scale though yeah
well just asymmetry exists in lots of
markets right so you can go invest in
technology startups
right obviously bitcoin was a pretty big
opportunity et cetera
but i do think that um there's this
mindset difference
between bitcoin investors and maybe
other types of investors so most other
investors are looking at
shorter time horizons they're looking
for some sort of asymmetry
uh and it's much more of an investment
decision
taking dollars and i am putting it into
this and when i pull it out it's going
to be dollars
bitcoiners think of it in a much longer
time horizon and they look at almost
like saving
yeah so what i'm going to do is i'm
going to take dollars to got paid in but
i'm going to convert it to
actual money sound money and then over
time the purchasing power is going to
appreciate right which
it goes up in u.s dollar terms but
they're not trying to come back into
dollars right it's not a trade it's not
an investment in that sense it's just no
this is the asset this is how i'm going
to store my wealth so i'm going to
protect it yeah
i think that mindset difference is uh
important to understand yeah
and then if you just say okay cool i'm
gonna do that with some portion of my
portfolio i'm not yet all the way there
in terms of like let me go put
everything in
and this global store value then i think
what people start looking for is these
asymmetric opportunities right and the
beauty of asymmetry is that you could
put smaller amounts of capital to work
and have kind of a higher payoff
and so i just tend to tell people like
don't go looking in the crypto markets
for asymmetry
yeah because they're it's riddled with
scams
uh like actual scams people use that
word but like actual things where
they're trying to take your money
uh and then it's really really hard for
most regular people to
underwrite what are the opportunities
like investing in businesses which we've
had you know decades and decades and
decades of kind of
uh historical precedent and work done to
say hey how do you evaluate a business
is hard yeah now imagine all these new
things that no one really understands
yet and everyone's trying to figure it
out and the professionals are still
trying to figure it out
it's just hard right well and that's why
i think that con i actually really like
the way you put it with that
asymmetry term right i mean i think like
looking for that and i guess you know
one thing i thought of like you were
talking about asymmetry capital
opportunities like for me
starting my business was sort of like an
asymmetry just like more like
opportunity period and it had less to do
with the capital like when people asked
me like hey why are you driving for uber
and lyft like i didn't know that i was
going to start this huge digital media
business it would be my new career
in seven years i'd be on this famous
pump podcast but
um you know it was like it was a low
risk thing to try and i feel like i have
tried many of those things in my life
that are like low risk
interesting opportunity something i'm
also passionate about and the
third thing i like is that it like helps
people right so i guess for me like i
look for
you know those three things help people
interesting make money
and just kind of keep looking for that
stuff i always tell people your salary
is not going to make you rich right so
owning a small business whether you're
driving whether you're doing digital
media or something else that's the path
to financial freedom
yeah cool appreciate it thank you so
much for doing this we're definitely
gonna do it again in the future
i'm around thank you sir